salam-o-alaikum what happen today better
care to brothers and sisters and dear
friends welcome to another show from
Saddam Studios so today I'll be reacting
to a well the Muslim lady the new show
in one part network I'll be reacting to
a Muslim sister and we're going to hear
what she has to say is that a Fendi bag
her husband got her stunning I need an
upgrade to my lounge look at how species
as Muslim women we are bombarded with
content every day from friends to
retailers to advertisers and don't get
me started about influences now while
most of us would rather brush off our
online activity as a fun way to pass
time I think it's best to take a second
look we seem to be in an endless stream
of content and studies are suggesting
this is having a negative impact on
women around the world we are constantly
being fed information that is of no
value is in any of our business and
worst of all content that is making us
jealous of one another and insecure with
who we are like perfect I want to stop
there three key points the sister
mentions and after you watch this video
please please please go and subscribe to
one part Network this initiative that
they've done is absolutely beautiful
absolutely amazing sisters if you're
watching this please go subscribe
inshaallah and this is something that
salam studio is what we like we look up
to this and we would like to do
inshaallah cuz it's very key for our
sisters to have a voice and inshallah be
a good role model because we have a lot
of bad role models and may Allah guide
us and them and us as well when I hate
to look down on anur but she's made some
very key points it has no value not our
business and makes us jealous this is
very very key brothers and sisters here
because as sisters I personally know
lots of people who their marriages have
been breaking breaking down and there is
an epidemic of divorces left right
center people that if I told you you
would be like no and I'll be lucky yes
and why is this happening obviously as
you guys know inshallah very soon
inshallah the Mars documentary I always
talk about I'm not gonna give you a date
with giving us dating sure I was gonna
be released we're gonna see in the
trailer I'm sure we're just coming
various
the exactly is gonna release and this is
something fundamentally so dear and
close to my heart because what's
happening is that our sisters and it's
also prophecies well that we are
comparing our sisters are comparing
their lives to other people and it is
all fake what do I mean by this I do not
mean by this that the person and
Instagram coupled a Muslim couple going
out there and saying oh yeah we're gonna
be fake today and even though we know a
very popular case that happened where
people were making dois oh Allah make
our marriage like that and you had no
idea what was going on and you was
actually making dua and a lot of you
guys often Kate what came out you
actually said you know Allah please do
not answer that door because you was
just looking at face-value aesthetics
and thinking wow and this is what we do
we compare our lives with other people
and what does it do it destroys it just
brings misery and that's what they say
comparison is the root of ungratefulness
on on the the killer of joy or something
along those lines okay
this is very important and what are they
doing is they're showing the best parts
of their life any picture or a video
when a picture is being taken or videos
encoded nobody goes and starts crying
for the sake of it everybody wants to
look good smile you're told
smile say cheese why do you say cheese
because you love cheese no I love
cheese's or blue cheese blue cheese
specifically but that's not why I say
cheese because when I say cheese smiling
you have to smile even if you're looking
sad and this is the reason why these
couples unintentionally or some
intentionally are putting it out there
and it's poisoning the minds of our
youngsters inshallah which I'm going to
bring case that is in ameri documentary
how it destroys from the get-go before
you get married because you have an
expectation how it should be and when
you get married you're thinking I didn't
sign up for this I didn't think it was
gonna be like this very key but let's
carry on watching bonuses in the shallow
and insecure with who we are like do we
really need to know what her house
husband and children look like when we
don't really know this person in real
life this knowing such information
add any value to our lives or is it just
feeding our inner curiosity to sneak
into the lives of others this is a trait
we best avoid as much as possible as the
prophet sallallaahu salam stated from
the perfection of one's islam is that he
leaves that which doesn't concern you
not only does such information add no
value to our lives but it is in turn
inviting feelings of envy jealousy and
insecurity whether it's the
materialistic wealth their physical
beauty or even their relationships this
exposure is damaging our ability to be
content
studies show that young women are
quickly developing negative perceptions
of their body image while older women
are continuing to develop feelings of
inadequacy when comparing their
lifestyles to the insta ready social
lives and careers of others online it's
no surprise at all that psychologists
are already advising us to unfollow all
those who are making us feel this way
that's exactly what we have to do
unfollow those people who bring no
benefits your life
yeah don't follow them first number one
is it's none of our business how their
life is etc but it's very key to
understand this our sisters females are
made to feel more uglier and uglier and
uglier and it's dismantling the female
mind yeah because this insecurity is
growing oh that person has that bad
their lifestyle like this you have no
idea you have no idea if their husband
is beating them up behind the scenes you
have no idea if our husbands even
practicing all you're doing is you're
seeing his image and you're judging by
that yeah and they're showing the best
bit and let the sister sit here
unfollow them if these people are making
you feel like that and they're giving
you a false perception unfollow them
it's as simple as that very very
important to us forget that the majority
of those we follow online present
filtered versions of their lives that
aren't true representations of reality
most online personalities only post
their most glamorous moments and the
highlights of their lives while hiding
away all the bits they don't want people
to know about how many Power couples
online have ended up in divorce
we looked up to them as relationship
goals how many social media influencers
were caught leading fake lives after we
took them as our inspiration we need to
remember to be content with whatever
Allah has given us and turn away from
constantly lusting after the lives of
others as Allah States in the or n and
do not wish for that which Allah has
made some of you exceed others if we
really want to peep into the lives of
anyone else to draw comparisons let it
be those who are below us in status be
it the poor or the needy
perhaps that would teach us to be
content and prevent us from ever
undermining the blessings we already
have exactly and this course for
prophecies will what happens is we tend
to as men yeah as men what do we tend to
do we tend to not lower our case and
that destroys marriages why because
you're on Instagram you keep looking at
other woman other females who are kicked
up yeah and I hope that's not a term
that's used somewhere else like I mean
like all makeup etc yeah and they
looking like that and you're thinking oh
man my wife you know my wife doesn't
look like that or look at and you start
looking at more harm stuff like oh look
at her hips all the middle ah look at
her this and that and that and what do
you do you're starting to compare your
wife to something that is not real yes
yes I'll be honest even they are not
real because most of these sisters I'll
be honest with you understand advice
that I give in my marriage documentary
is that in a marriage meeting or
wherever it may be on Instagram
once the makeup comes off I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry sisters to break this to
you yes I'll be honest with you but you
don't look like that now this does not
mean you're ugly no no no no no you're
actually more beautiful without the
makeup cause my bat is just a new true
self
I know stories but marry somebody and
she takes the makeup off and he says
Jenny I wouldn't be lying Nash a tiny
regime bismillah r-rahman r-rahim now
why not because he deems her to be may
be unattractive he may be he does say
that because of that but the issue here
is this when you're putting on something
but you're not that thing it's
misleading
yeah I'm not gonna go a sister's promise
do that in many ways or have this money
this
sister forcefully he's broke yeah he's
broke he doesn't have money to buy
himself halal chicken mushroom pie
yeah he's broke so the thing here is
this when you do that be real when you
get to know stuff that's why I highly
encourage when you watch the manors
document you can understand how to go
about seeking marriage because P real
look this is how I look this is me I'm
not gonna come and lie to you and say
hey you know you know see this jacket
etc let me be real with you guys I'm
gonna be extra with you guys you know
why because I believe there's a reason
why everything happens you see this what
I'm wearing here this is Hugo Boss yep
you've seen that that's you go boss
honey that was wearing Hugo Boss yep you
heard it right do you know where I got
this jacket from I've got this jacket
from a charity shop
I repeat that maybe you didn't hear it
this is Hugo Boss firstly I didn't buy
it cause a superboss about because it
looks quite nice I bought it in a
charity shop yes now this is not cause
I'm super broke neither does the Hugo
Boss mean I'm super rich I was an email
channel who was filming for a podcast
talk to me show and I forgot to bring
certain clothes they said go to his
charity shop to buy some shirts I said
okay no problem and you see I'm a leave
out with a great honorable gentleman how
dare you say that - such a gentleman
like myself no I went there and I bought
some shirts and that's what is shocking
there for you this looks nice fun it
looks nice now how many of you may have
watch this would be like good TV here
background you know his Apple thing and
he's got his jacket you have no idea
about my life you have no idea of been
through what I may be still going
through you have no idea about my
marital life you have no idea what my
family you don't know nothing all you
see is this specific video done in the
specific time and all you've seen is oh
nice jacket nice jacket brother there
you go a charity shop yeah though I'm
the way it keeps me warm no problem
the reason I'm mentioning this to you is
because of that and once you're
confident within yourself you don't care
like love hamdulillah
one is happy within itself he doesn't
care about this or this because I am NOT
this is not Ali yeah my child is this is
not Ali me my internally I'm Ali and
this is very important for us to
understand is brother and sisters let's
carry on watching each other
let it be people who uplift our
spirituality let it be people who are in
self centric and ego driven rather ask
yourself how is this person making me
feel about myself and is this person
going to benefit my religious status so
if they aren't helping you do yourself a
favor and unfollow absolutely I am being
honest with you guys this is a project I
will try my best to push out brothers
and sisters sisters sisters sisters
please please please please
I think that's me for the magical
chemistry gonna be a mad one inshallah
inshallah very soon
please please socio why'd you have to
come and read not them sorry anyways
please make sure you guys sign subscribe
to this beautiful reminded shala and do
not let these people with their fake
lives make you feel bad about yourself
and make you feel like you that's the
norm that's not the normal marriage this
doesn't work with you know you come home
you know come to my wife afro flowers
nah fam you know sometimes there's
Friedrichs not literal effectives please
calm down
yeah this happens often you're sick to
be said may Allah bless you guys
inshallah may Allah bless you guys for
watching
assalamu alaikum what am i talk about
okay we're gonna have more videos that
we're gonna react to variety of topics
with guests in sha allah assalamu
alaikum